with all the stuff that's going on
there's a few characters i'm curious
about with you so one you fought a lot
of different guys okay
uh and you fought different styles of
guys in
ufc
who to you you say when this guy punches
it's the heavy he packs a punch who's
above everybody i know we can say
everybody packs a good punch right was
there anybody that you said i felt this
guy's punch conor mcgregor no doubt
about it you put connor at the top yeah
that as the best biggest puncher i
thought yes yeah
yeah she's special special individual
for sure
wow and and you fought in what you
fought him uh 14 and then 21-21 fought
him in 2014
lost and that was on his
you know in his trajectory was just
sky was the limit he was on his way up
and he tore through everybody became a
two-way world champion
but
yeah and i fought him twice this year
so this year when you get the first
fight the second fight the third fight
do you feel any different when he packs
his punch or is still the same still the
same very dangerous it's just i i've i
felt differently
mentally going into it
you think the biggest difference between
you and 14 21 is mental or is it skills
as well some areas where you saw some
weaknesses where you can exploit
for sure my skills got better over the
years
you know all the work wasn't done in
vain but my middle side is what lost me
that first fight you know and what won
me these last two fights that's two
fights uh uh ground if you were to say
somebody who you went up against went up
against that ground game it's just
khabib nurmagomedov
yeah would you put him like in a league
of his own a lot of people call him as
the league of his own type of guy would
you ever felt anything like it you know
and i have 46 fights i've fought all
kind of different people all kind of
different styles
been around the world training in gyms
this guy
this guy's good what's what's unique
about it tell us about me
his understanding of his weight
distribution where my weight needs to be
to keep me up to build back up and and
his understanding of uh grappling is is
impressive is i mean the best i've ever
felt the best i've ever seen you know
the guys 30-0
and mma that's a hard thing to do
there's so many variables there's so
many ways to lose and to be 30-0
against the best guys in the world
is
you know very impressive but
his understanding of what i needed to do
and what positions i needed to be in
to advance
he was he was steps ahead of me so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]